ice melts cracks and pulls away from the  mainland the water is still a  bone-chilling 35 degrees cold enough to  freeze a human in a matter of minutes  but perfect for young polar bears out  with their mom  for most of the year their world is ice  open water is a novelty which is why  what you're about to see is so rare  these to practice a type of swimming  usually seen in underwater mammals  it's called porpoising  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  polar bears live on an opposite schedule  to other animals in Alaska winter is  when they hunt on the ice indeed summer  melts their ice they have no choice but  to fast they swim and lays in the Sun  with empty bellies  [Music]  [Music]  you